Final Fantasy 15 you and a feel that
people got the chance to play at the
preview build which is pretty massive
from my understanding but you
specifically played 15 hours like the
first five chapters like walk us through
what you got the chance to check out
yeah so it was the first five chapters
which technically is about like give or
take one 12 ish hours yeah but like I
spent a few hours doing a lot of like
side content so yeah you just start you
off in beginning the game and throws you
off right into the open world basically
yeah yeah so I don't really know the
series all that well I mean I know I
like in passing enough to like
understand why it's important and why
people love it but correct me if I'm
wrong this is the first like truly open
world final fantasy is that incorrect or
is that misleading it depends on how you
look at it yeah like I mean you probably
from what I understand you can't just go
anywhere from the start yeah that's true
but it's big like in the way that the
MMOs are big right like you're strong
enough if you have the abilities you can
get there okay yeah but you did say like
pretty soon after you started you were
in like just an open world right yeah
that's what's different I want to say
compared to a lot of the other previous
final fantasies that have had similar
sort of qualities to it that you're
literally thrown into the open world
within the first ten minutes which you
know what's bob has a 13 that took while
over like 20 or so hours to show me my
34 tile even though but that's that's a
long injury but uh but yeah I think
that's sort of the most distinct quality
of it um did it feel like there's a lot
to do or was it kind of you i member you
i read your preview we were editing in
you said there's a lot of fetch quests
that it was there a lot of substance the
quest you're doing or with just kind of
running around fetching things for
people getting tasks done yet see that's
the thing like you do there are a lot of
side quests that emerge besides sort of
the main stuff that you get to do most
of those they do follow a very standard
fetch quest format sometimes a little
too much where it's like hey go to point
a get this thing go to point B give it
to that person and then go back to point
point ada in order to complete the quest
and some some of the cool some quests
don't really add that
much in terms to the overall so if
context of the conflict that takes place
in the game so it can be a little like
it doesn't really feel like there's not
a ton of substance every yeah a ton of
substance sure so to say yeah can you
walk you through the world itself is
such a weird I mean I know Final Fantasy
always kind of does this but there's
it's like this weird amalgamation of
like magic and weird like highway see
and reality highway 69 diners and cars
and boys and leather I don't know 69
diners and boys and leather what is
highway 1666 that the one yes route 60
sorry guys in the gutter oh Jesus I'm a
69 diner as much as the next books Oh
houses world feel that you Matt to avoid
beats conversation um as you said
there's a lot of I guess the way
described it's very inspired by sort of
Americana kind of like you know having a
lot of sort of these pit stop areas
you're on basically that the aesthetic
of the game is very much a road trip so
that's kind of what leads you through a
lead you through the story um sorry yeah
the world itself is like I mean it's a
weird kind of like you said it's like
this road trip thing I always got like I
member the first trailer is kind of like
that stand by me cover by that girl I
don't I didn't get the aesthetic they're
going for it all I've been trying to pay
attention to Final Fantasy 15 but it
seems like they're going for so many
different things in the world feel like
connected to you to feel engaging do you
want to go back and see more this world
now that you played like 15 hours of it
very much so um that's that's a thing
like I really there's a lot to do there
really is it's a very big game and a lot
of the stuff that you get to do really
emerges organically for the most part
despite some of the fetch quests nature
of the side activities you get to do but
there's just so many different places to
explore a lot of activities to do
besides you know even just fetch quest
of course you could you just like pop on
a chocobo and explore you know and
that's what I really like about the game
it has a very distinct quality compared
to other final fantasies yeah like
what's this like it for me a good final
fantasy game has a certain spark to it
that like when you play it you're like
yeah this is Final Fantasy like no other
series kind of attaches such importance
to
a weird quirk like what is the quirk
that makes this feel like legitimately
Final Fantasy like it can't be the
chocobos it can't be the summons like
what is it about this RPG in particular
that feels like it fits in the series of
anything at this stage this dinosaur
ostrich is riding that's a chocobo you
don't I'm just trolling both of you know
I really didn't know every joke about
not the best one to talk about Final
Fantasy see that's a good question i
mean i think what makes this game
distinctly file fancy i think final
fantasy as a series has always been it's
always challenged itself to change and
to redefine itself and what it is either
that'd be like because you know when
fontax you first some of the earlier
games is very more traditional fantasy
setting but then you have seven which
kind of tells a little bit more into
these sort of steam punk aesthetic
changing what we can expect out of final
fantasy as a series i think that's what
15 does again that's what i like about
it it's contemporary look very
contemporary feel like everything is
just kind of modern day with you know a
dash of magic on it totally totally it
definitely ask that question of like you
know what what kind of final fantasy
game be well for 15 like yeah a final
fantasy game can be sort of this long
extended road trip that takes place on
sort of a huge open world it can be a
game that does tights off closer to
reality and I think that's what 15 I
think it captures a file fans in general
this desire to kind of change things up
redefine itself throughout the years
cool the end a couple specifics quick
we're watching combat are now how'd that
feel when you're playing cuz you said in
your preview played you had like an
extensive time with that as well combat
feels great I really like it a lot it's
okay so it's more action focused it's
not very much it's not like sort of a
turn-based battle system that we've seen
in sort of previous games it's real time
yeah yeah definitely you can play by
pausing it and you can you can't
actually I've tried out that mode a
little bit because it's what it does is
like you know in the middle of action if
you don't move it'll just pause the
action and you have a little time bar
that moves that just basically gives you
like a limited time to think don't like
fast you next a little fall out very
similar actually yeah
um but yeah the the comet system in
general is revising a lot of like an
action game like sort of more hardcore
action game like doublemint cry
bayonetta nor near as sort of complex as
those systems as demanding but it
definitely gives you a lot of room to be
stylish in your combat because you have
a lot of different you can equip
different types of weapons that have
their own distinct attacks that you can
literally switch to on the fly as you're
beating up a dude okay so but like
overall in general after 15 hours of
this you sound pretty positive on you
sound like you want to play it again
when it releases one November remember
30th however 30ml vespertine finally got
too late a couple times yeah but you
sound positive just for like years yeah
it's a little welcome 10 years in the
making though yeah whatever yeah overall
like despite some of the issues that
might have had with sort of the fetch
quest nature of it all and even some
bits with the story which I'm really
doubled up on too much yet but um I am
very excited to return to the world I
really want to see because I really want
to see what this game has to offer
because it's very promising there's a
lot of different things that make it so
distinct of itself redefining some of
the things that I've come to expect from
Final Fantasy over the years that you
know I just really want dive in and see
what happens cool awesome a lot I mean I
don't really play the series but it
looks like something am I going to try
out a five-time my Pete you're probably
super excited for this I'm pretty
excited yeah I'm super apprehensive but
I'm but I'm excited yeah well I the game
actually opens with its winter esting
how the game it opens with the message
saying like a final fantasy for fans and
first-timers so could be part of that
first timer a lot man okay interesting I
you know like ideally each sequel would
be for first-timers as well but yes Joe
maybe they worked around this time cool
that is final fancy 15 you can read our
full preview its up on site we have some
video content as well both from NS
pinellia and that releases November 30th
so tell us what you think are you
excited for it leave your thoughts in
the comments below
[Music]